What's up everyone today we're learning
English with the superstar pop singer and
Disney Channel actress Selena Gómez. In this
lesson we'll help you to understand aspects
of pronunciation with some of her biggest hits
as well as learning new vocabulary. But before
we get into it and in case you're new here
we are here to help you learn fast English,
without getting lost , without missing
the jokes and without subtitles.
Just like this fan who says that our channel is
so interesting to learn English with. So be sure
to hit that subscribe button and bell down below
so that you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Do you struggle to understand fast speaking
natives? Then I highly recommend our Fluent with
Friends Course. In this 48 week Course you'll
learn with the first two seasons of Friends!
You'll receive PDF Power Lessons every
week, vocabulary Memorization Software,
access to our Fluency Circle Global Community
and so much more! And did you know you can try it
right now for free with our Three-Part
Masterclass! All you have to do is click
up here or down in the description box
below to learn more and sign up now!
if you're a fan of learning English with
music then I highly recommend you check
out this playlist where you'll find lots
of different songs and artists to choose
from. You're bound to find someone you
love! So you'll find that by clicking
up here or down in the description
box below to choose your next lesson.